i wanted to be the first to welcome you
to casual season and here's what i mean
by casual season effect the friday the
day after thanksgiving
black friday cyber monday we go for this
six
week casual season people get sloppy
they show up to work later they don't
stick to their disciplines they say the
average person during holidays
puts on five to ten pounds you get your
energy goes
lower you're already in christmas
holiday mode new year's eve mode
and you're already living into 2021 just
want you to know
95 of people are going to get this bug
of holiday season and they're going to
get very casual
and since 2002 till today i have
loved this season here's what's crazy i
love thanksgiving
but i love thanksgiving day i love
christmas i love christmas
i love family coming together on
christmas it's my favorite holiday by a
mile
i love these two dates but at the same
time
december for me historically is one of
the busiest days of the month
i do a lot of business planning strategy
sessions get togethers gatherings
we get to again think about what we're
going to be doing in 2021 we have
carrier meetings that we bring everybody
together a lot of people are saying i
can't make it i can't come i can't do
this it doesn't matter we're holding
this meeting
to talk about a good bad ugly every
single thing we do for 2021 happens in
november december all the planning
and at the same time historically
november is a very big month for us
december is a very big month for us
because we like to finish off and by the
way for some of you that may say that
maybe because your industry
it's got nothing to do with the industry
insurance industry is very slow in the
month of december
insurance industry is slow the week
pre-thanksgiving
till new year's it's not a good industry
to be a part of because at six week
insurance agents pretty much take it off
the insurance carriers take off
their customer service starts later
their customer service finishes earlier
everybody's off during this season but
why am i sharing this message with you
here's why you know it's one of the
hardest things to do in the month of
december i'm gonna tell you what's one
of the hardest things to do in
the month of december especially in a
weird like like like this that we had in
2020 which at this point everybody knows
it's been a weird year
covet market election voter fraud
whatever you want to call it biden
trump you know uh riots protesting blm
whatever you want to call it this has
been a very weird year
it's a qualified weird year by a mile
however
however the hardest thing for people to
do
in december is to get their business
plan out they they wrote
in december of 2019 it's the hardest
thing to do so hard to take out your
business plan
you know why it's hard to take out the
business plan because why would you want
to look at a business plan that you only
get fifty percent of gold done
or you only got forty percent of gold
done some of you guys that are you know
did really well eighty percent of gold
done
typically what i've known from my career
somebody that doesn't hit sixty percent
of their goal
of the year they wrote out in their
business plan they don't even look at
their business plans the biggest mistake
you'll ever make
if you don't look at a terrible business
plan where you didn't hit your numbers
why because if you don't look at it
what's going to change the next year
the first thing we do like we've already
started this a month and a half ago two
months ago
where we sit down with our board and our
board says that we hit our budget
without numbers what's on what's off
what did we get the other day we were
looking at our numbers that we projected
last december of what we're going to do
in september october
uh it was august september october do
you know what we hit of our goals
103 of budget 97 of budget
99 of budget meaning we said
last december what we're going to do in
the month of august september november
september october and we hit it within
97 99
100 by the way don't let me impress you
for 15 years we didn't
okay i'm telling you this is the guy
that was winging
first 10 years of my business i was
winging i'm just kind of like energy
let's go we can do it all this other
stuff
oh we had don't worry about let's look
at the numbers let's go it's about next
year it's not about looking at the past
it's about next year we don't need to
look at all this stuff
and then i started hanging out with
people that are actually winning at the
highest level and i realized what they
do
they actually go back and look at the
bad news they actually go back and look
at the stuff they didn't pull off
they actually go back and find out all
the things that they said they were
going to do that they didn't execute
why not and they have the tough
conversations and they improve
so what does this mean to you a couple
things it means to you number one
if you're in the 95 the category of
people that are
already checked out and it's already
thanksgiving you ate so much this turkey
was so good the stuffing oh my gosh
family
black friday's if you're in that
community but you're willing to be
convinced to go to the five percent
community
this is your chance to do so when you're
watching this video because it's still
not too late but i tell you if you wait
you don't recover january when everybody
gets to work if you take the six weeks
off you know how long it takes for
people to recover
add another six weeks which means you
take the six weeks off of being casual
and you come back around january 4th 5th
let's just say monday tuesday
you're not going to recover for six
weeks after that which is middle of
february
by the time you recover by middle of
february which means your your year is
really starting march 1st
you're already toast you ain't competing
with the real competitors you're
competing with the bottom eighty percent
that's who you're competing with
if you want to compete with the top five
percenters in november
finish off strong december finish off
strong look at every single thing you
did right wrong whatever it happened
any surprises one of the things we love
spending time with it's areas that we
have surprises
and this year we have a lot of surprises
i'm talking about for myself
a lot of surprises as a ceo as a parent
as a family as a business as in the
it's been so many surprises this year so
what's made me
do is just kind of calculate what
surprises i'm going to be ready for next
year
so if it happens again like some people
are saying oh my gosh we're getting the
second wave of covet we're getting the
third wave of code we are fully prepared
because we've been through this already
so it's not a surprise to us because you
know we know what's going to be
happening
everything i'd be thinking about if i
were you is go back at the business plan
see what you didn't hit ask yourself why
you didn't hit it
and ask how much weight does your word
have are you the kind of person that
keeps saying what you're going to do and
you don't hit
but 20 of your goals well maybe that's a
character issue
maybe that's a work ethic issue maybe
it's you got to keep your word it's not
easy to have this conversation believe
me i've had this conversation with
myself
for a long time and i eventually made a
decision back in 0708 i said
i want to be the guy that when i walk in
and i'm getting the investors
clients whoever i'm talking to i want to
say if we're going to hit this number
we're either going to hit the number or
they're going to say let me tell you
they hit 92 of it they hit 88 of it
these guys one thing i know about these
guys they're gonna bust their tail
to hit the number that they gave i
wanted that kind of a reputation amongst
my peers
carriers investors partners everybody
which brought new partners in so if you
want to do that
going into 2021 don't wait until 2021 to
change those habits
finish december in 2020 strong
don't go into 2021 yet finish december
in 2020
strong this month strong then going to
with a ton of momentum and then you own
2021.
if you do that 2021 with all the havoc
that's still going to happen
still going to be weird inauguration new
president potentially
with all the havoc you're not gonna have
a lot to worry about
because you're gonna experience the
beginning of the greatest years of your
life simply because
you your new version came into 2021
having said that if you've never watched
a video i did a one-page business plan i
made this video i believe four years ago
if you've never watched a click over to
watch this video and start your business
planning for 2021
and with that being said have a great
week everybody take care bye
you